hey guys welcome back to a brand new
video we're back on four on again a
little bit weird to see you guys not on
a Thursday especially in the afternoon
times it's actually like Sunday night
which is pretty interesting for me so
you know it's always nice to get a
little bit of a surprise in here but
yeah you read the title we're gonna be
discussing something that people have
been bringing up that I've seen in my
own game that I want to kind of show to
you guys that maybe you guys have also
seen in your matches as well recently
this past day cuz I don't believe it's
been happening yesterday but I believe
it happened just about today and it's
probably gonna continue throughout the
rest of this week or so is that the
attacking minions so far that I've seen
on Reddit have actually had their
shields changed you're gonna be seeing
images for multiple people on reddit of
all different types of different
factions the Vikings the Knights the
samurai all of them on the attacking
side have the emblems changed to the
black stone Legion who is the you know
the leader of that is apollyon so this
is kind of a weird little teaser that
we're getting not just a case of course
you haven't put the campaign the black
stone Legion is the main antagonist of
the entire group which is why the three
main factions are really at war cuz it
was probably going to stop if it wasn't
for her and her wanting to basically
have a giant war go on which is kind of
what she started but it begs the
question though what's this about in the
past seasons and other stuff we've had
many teasers we had the giant obelisks
which ended up teasing the Raving
Rabbids which was kind of a weird teaser
but still kind of interesting also there
was the runes that were shown throughout
some of the Viking maps in the game
teasing the you the new your man Gunder
event which we had last season stuff
like that so this stuff isn't new but
it's what is it exactly talking about
the problem is that you know we're a
couple days away from getting the new
event but also a couple days ago we also
got the new teaser for the year for
content and you know people are
suspecting that that one arm within the
picture is a polygons hand and you know
anybody could say whatever they want
some people say Centurion some people
say apollyon some people say a minion
now everyone's got different opinions
but it's what it is what it is
totally ignoring the fact that I'm one
HP about to die by a conqueror behind me
but I had to check it out actually
in-game yes it does believe that the
color changes have actually not just
been the shield and the emblem but it's
also the fact that the
are also color black now as they you
know the attackers used to be originally
orange and it also seems like the
defenders have no changes whatsoever
which kind of sucks but I think there's
a little bit of a reasoning for that as
well so as you guys see it looks like
the defenders have nothing changed and
also the attackers are getting a totally
different revamp in terms of their color
scheme seeing a lot more blacker colors
whereas we normally don't see that we
see orange on their chess piece
especially in the Vikings case where
it's everywhere is orange so I've been
seeing a lot of theories of what people
have been talking about on reddit and
this could be any number of things like
I said this could be a teaser for the
new event coming to the game this could
be it's easier for the new year and if
it does happen to be with the event is
this going to be something like a
polygon legacy are we going to be is
that going to be returning as the new
event which I don't really think is
likely the case because they the
developers had said that every single
season of this year is going to be some
event dedicated to the lore of the
character of that season this season
being soon da so we're probably going to
be getting an event based on that if
that is to be true of course with if
appalling of legacy is to be coming back
it'll probably happen somewhere within
year 4 which of course I'm totally cool
with the polygons legacy tester metal
being one of the best seasons ever one
of the events one of the best events
ever made in the game so I'd totally be
down to see that come back cuz a lot of
people even in the people that have been
talking to my streams and comments have
actually never gotten to play it and
it's actually really sad because it's
such a good mode another thing of course
like I pointed out is that the it's only
on the attacker side which of course you
know apollyon is always about the being
on the offense so that kind of fits so
maybe this has to do with something of
the black stone Legion coming up again
and then fighting or something let me
know what you guys think about that in
the comments below I figured there's a
lot of different things we can interpret
from just this coming out what this
specifically is teasing and then of
course once we figure out what it's
teasing was it about yeah if you have
any of those theories let me know in the
comments below like leave if you do
enjoy guys subscribe if you're new I
cover the informational side of
foreigner that being the balance changes
they hear updates the Patrick's and the
leaks if want to be kept updated with
everything happens in the world of
Warner I never miss out on an update
deficits got the channel that guys take
care of it goes today I'll see you all
on Thursday for the event news and peace
out
you